that's not the plan
did the traditional magazines at the
time
um
were they Peyton or they did they
embrace you because at the time there's
like this weird
like
I don't know man there's like thesaurus
that really turned into like a weirdo
magazine for a little bit and then you
know obviously Elliot Wilson was running
it up running circles around him at XXL
for a sec and you know it felt like such
a competitive space I have some funny
stories about that I mean and so we're
moving a little forward like by this
time you know 2005-ish like you guys
have been up and running for a while
realizing like there's really some money
in this right
um and I think what showed me too like
the early issues I might send I'd send
like a box to like Montgomery Alabama or
something and I'd send like four boxes
to Miami thinking like oh Miami's a
bigger market and people in Miami I mean
they liked it but they were kind of like
they have you know three radio stations
and they have yeah they have Boomin City
places to go like the artists there
don't really need right a platform
whereas I would get like 100 calls from
Montgomery all these DJs artists people
that want to get down so I started to
see there was a market and you know the
south is full of Tallahassee
Jacksonville you know Birmingham I mean
there's there's so many like Tennessee
mid-level markets that just don't have
at that time they didn't have social
media so if they're there's an artist
they're trying to get on they don't have
you to to show people what they look
like so you know they would advertise in
the magazine so I saw that there was a
real Market there so uh Elliott Wilson
um saw him yesterday a couple days ago
so I mean we're cool and stuff but he's
always been one to kind of like take
shots at different people so
funny story about him
um well I remember at one point I would
go to New York and I would like drop off
magazines places so I stopped by double
XL one time just to drop off some
magazines and he was like the only
person in the office I think was like
eight o'clock in the evening or whatever
and I just remember him he said uh oh
you're not you're not from around here
are you like it was to me it was like
people in New York kind of I don't know
if you meant it to be like like I took
it a certain way I don't know that he
meant it that way but to me somebody
from if I asked somebody where they're
from and they say like Houston or the
Bay right or L.A like I kind of have a
sense of like where they're from and
right what kind of you know environment
they're dealing with and I felt like New
Yorkers had this idea like you're either
from New York or you're not and it's
it's one or the other you know what I
mean that's that's kind of how I
perceived it was like oh you're not from
here so you're just I don't really care
where you're from I don't know where
you're from yeah so that's kind of how I
took it but later on like maybe a couple
years down the road
um we had never been able to get a
distribution deal not that I I don't
know that I put a whole lot of effort
into it but it was always like a street
kind of of things like you're getting
your own printing done and you're
everything yeah load up the van drive to
you know yeah because I would see your
guys's stuff at like record stores like
small like independent record stores
like I think I might have saw it at like
Tower Records
we eventually did get a distribution
deal so I had been trying there's
there's really at that time there might
have been like two or three Distributors
but there's really only like one big
distributor which is Curtis and they did
you know double XL and source and all
that and I would have thought they were
the same distributor so there was this
yeah they were Distributing both
they were Distributing like any
newsstand you go to you know right
pretty much goes through Curtis at least
from from what I recall and I had you
know send them copies of the magazine
and they sent us like this standard like
rejection letter or whatever and
um I hired a consultant to try to harass
them and try to get us a distribution
deal but I said something about double
XL in my editorial and Elliot responded
like he he put a little line or
something about ozone or whatever and so
I copied it and sent it because he would
write his little like he was always
taking shots you know the sauce and like
all this stuff but he said something
about like oh go down south with the
ozone or like it was something that
could be interpreted as like a disc back
to us so I copied it sent it to the
distributor and I don't know if that was
what did it or the consultant or
whatever but we got a distribution deal
and so it kind of so shout out to him
like you know if you're Distributing
this product and they're like you know
now if you're battling with somebody
they're an equal basically so
um but the source I mean I I started I
met boo Rosario
um pretty early on he was a music editor
or one of the music editors at the
source and he did the the photo
galleries in the back so I started
sending him stuff and I would be super
excited if I got like you know my little
so you were getting your picks sometimes
in the back of the source yeah so I want
a photography I would send them like
hundreds of pictures and they might pick
you know yeah yeah two or three months
might make it but I'll be excited about
that and I so I met Kim and uh you know
shout out to Kim when she was she was
the editor at that point she had come
down to Miami I think to shoot um Trina
or something and you know I would kind
of throw it out there like you guys
should hire me to you know work this out
like I didn't feel like anyone took that
super seriously but they did start
giving me like a little assignment here
and there and
um that's when they were I think
starting to fall apart as far as the
yeah on the on the business side and
also the Eminem thing was going on right
right it was it was a lot happening
about